nice the NHANES impedes is too pro for
you right my I've never played with any
of you before so I don't know your
strategies either oh oh I just know
marks yeah so basically to be on really
logical really it's a good conspicuous
prop that no one whatever choose see you
don't think that anyone would yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's so funny watching this a
spectator it really is I just really
[ __ ] up like an unbelievable level
just wholly getting out more details
about how you eff this up please
exposure good well not makes how you
doing over there
I'm doing fine which one you just jump
uh how do I jump spacebar how does one
jump in a video game yeah this is gonna
be good hey come ha ha yeah I'm Nick you
do a team that gray yeah f 2 necro joins
him oh good even know what idiot Wow
okay so mm-hmm-hmm any plans minx or can
we just sort of generally panic when
they realize bobba bobba fett what was
with the music at the end that was your
death music na ba ba ba but the only
question is is the mix in here as well
the question is am I to pray the amok
mixes on the pro side I is a sneaky
sneaky position is it
so are we playing are we playing with
the rules where you can't hide behind
something are we doing that plain sight
fine sight I'm Michael broke the rules
rule dry balls okay I know now and ER
are we doing hints as well yes with the
other hits um
[Music]
how can we in the mall didn't record the
other side I mean I recorded them but
there the other video was so crappy I
don't think it exists
I think anything happened ooh okay so
what really really large object are you
going to be like I haven't unli
I have not unleashed the large object
strategy at them yet
I really have not seen they have not
seen it yet I know what will wear the
props on this map I don't see them yeah
this could be trouble okay well oh here
we go have been unleashed
is it a role that we need to stay in the
compound nope oh right I know nothing to
see them to see here that's our
discussion okay okay I could let go
innocent Meryl if you um if you answer
my questions okay okay it's your
favorite color you have you read America
yes okay I mean I live there yes that's
a good on some one final question okay
and if you want to Rick right bill you
all right what's 2+2 is this a trick
question
cuz I would say he doesn't have mercy on
me let's being very nice ah yummy mash
you came from the wrong direction I was
hoping to swing by someone they would
say you were supposed to have mercy on
me as well but you didn't hey you won my
specimen right you are you are very kind
I might have to return the favor
exactly don't do it you don't know mix
you don't know mix don't do it do not
trust do not trust mix almost as bad as
manners yeah almost as bad as manners
let's just be honest here okay
I am she's trying to get on your good
side right now I'm glad that everyone
categorizes me as that but I'm really
nice I can't eat oh hi Jaime
okay I've got a plan is it good no
yes ah why would I follow you then I'm
an no there there neither of the barrels
okay just go get aside just go here
right here i'ma wait here okay
all right beautiful okay so um anyway
yeah me how are you oh yeah not too bad
yeah decent weather I suppose oh it's
gotten pretty dark oh yeah
but there are only a few crops I we were
just chilling out in the gazebo having a
great time to be found Nick hurry
something markedly different but he is
massively obvious oh goody
I'm really like good to be honest you're
looking at your tail on my screen you're
facing away from the thing that you're
trying to face yeah that's a problem
dumb it or something
ID pick a really large one like a bed or
something all that thanks for that I'm
gonna find you there
now well you're not that surprising
you're not that surprising wow just
insulting more why don't you I should
have put a comma between the words mmm
Jesus MacRay really where is he I don't
know I don't know be something he's
something big he wasn't no big he's not
anymore no anymore he changed after we
gave him a little lecture let's just say
he could be on our bucket list
oh that was a very subtle hint huh yeah
he's a bed Eddy I get oh my god Marcus
not too pro today oh no that was good Oh
where we're going
where are you don't mess with me I could
I can help you was a bucket yes Wow
this is this is 2 V 3 so we are at a bit
of a disadvantage but yeah it's lovely
you'll know a long time Oh am i oh wait
you're right I am I don't know if I've
known for having proper skills I'm not
entirely sure that's that videos Matthew
you have you I mean I I do my best
by oh god oh god oh I watched unlike
Tonio videos mr. sparkles and then I
disliked marks stretch yes so I gotta
say I know it's I don't know I think
it's you over there but I'm not really I
need to stop following you the home to
attend sit right come on I'm gonna find
someone want to kill some oh really
that's a little aggressive yeah I'm
gonna get somebody come on good nice
poor crops think of this if it if its
minks it very well might be but other
feelings to you feelings feelings I have
the best idea ever
next round mine haha Oh God oh no it's
only major props please darn enough
plenty of promised weeds but least one
event with goodwill awareness your name
pops up sir I was oh yeah that would
that would definitely do it yeah
so I'm Evan why don't you give us a hint
I'm barely there you did the head last
hole God oh sorry you can't get using
the same wall um ah ha ha ha my emotions
are all bucketed up no you're killing it
was definitely better yeah well my oh my
goodness really
ok ok ok all right
well the happen necro being a noob its
you yah yah yah yah
I don't easy to poke the Yami bear Oh
Yami come on you just walked right by me
come on at this point in time you're
just being totally ridiculous yeah Holly
I can't find ya me at the moment almost
no they're really trolling with me I
have not will pass anything yes you have
Yami is that your weight is that you
that well yeah that's always yummy yeah
yeah you [ __ ] like twice in a row
[Laughter]
um let me another clue
uh I'm like a shadow in the night my
hiding spot blocks out the Sun Oh hiding
spot blocks countless yeah that's
interesting to say an extremely
overweight prop yeah I'm psyching piays
I have no idea to the building if you
block out the Sun because you are the
building right yes that's exactly what
it is he's the full building you are the
map I am the map oh you almost got me
whoever that is me house me those you
thing late these clues these clues may
have to adjust your clue mark um nah I
haven't changed files just something a
little more yeah like Oh about the same
dammit um uh I don't know I don't know
what to say anymore oh that's not very
helpful I I am I am I'm a something that
shouldn't be moving right now probably
shouldn't be moving cuz if I was spotted
boy I happen if you were spotted it was
that I would have I don't know is this
hard to run away from three people
I'm so confused it that way was was he a
book it it was a barrel I was gullible
he's always a barrel I wasn't lying
that was my clue I'm barely then Errol
bear early bear oh you just die already
don't even look that well that's wrong
down that didn't just happen I think it
did oh hey I think it did okay I had a
really good idea and I forgot what was
stem so really they could only be either
a barrel or a bucket on this man this
chairs and beds as long I'm much more
than this yeah pretty much
I'm liking yours they're yummy very
clever you know I would say one thing I
will change for a different prop every
every round so I won't be the same prop
every time
sparkles do you remember how I was
really nice when you were a barrel I
think you should be really nice to me if
you find me as a barrel this time
so you're a barrel yeah thanks for the
clue I might be a barrel I might be in
the street but mark don't come I
kneecaps Ibaka's come please wait what
in the straight you say a barrel easy I
don't know why you give it away that
quickly but ok I'm on my way
I don't know which Street you're at I
want to have a quiz so be fun with you
here just some doors close on this map
and stay close bah boppa bah bum bah
right somebody else is closing them Hey
no I mean I literally can't open them um
bum bum bum is that funny man with the
Craig BA mr. Spock
Oh oh hi ok you're just gonna it's
friendly barrel that just appeared ok ah
really barrel um I would like to give
you a quiz if you would like honky ok so
what is your favorite animal
my favorite animal I like small things
you like scorpions Dorian's that just
sounds not good at all on anima is why
would you say you like scorpions I'm not
sure about that answer it will ask me
another one I'm sure I'll give you a
much better answer what's your favorite
movie how fiction hope fiction is it
that's a good one I mean it's a little
bit.i it's probably shows up in people's
favorite movie lists pretty frequent ok
are we have to fear oh hi
good eyes I want to be
this is this is gonna be this is gonna
be the question for all questions and if
you answer incorrectly then I'm going to
get you both with one we're okay guys
sorry guys I'm gonna get both with one
grenade where are you guys make sure you
stand close together come in come in
Thanks
that's like a barrel blocking it all
right are you guys okay
I should ask a math a math question oh
[ __ ] um what is the area of a circle
with a radius of three all right make
sure you've got this I'm just where do
you just go I am nowhere to be sane it's
he but I I I think you got away I mixed
look I know I know try God because
you're right and look at the area of a
circle is gonna do it PI R squared
it is Pyrus my times three come on yummy
so glad it's pi times 9 so that's 90
plus 18 plywood I might would have been
satisfied with 9 pi cos pi is an
irrational number
yeah so hard to do this good this is
seriously over my head math come on yes
you 2+2 last time come on a bit hard hey
come on it's just it's very rough circle
it's nine pies yeah you do pie ours the
circumference of a circle
it's just nine nine pies don't you know
has your youtubing this made you forget
about your schooling you guys go
okay well that a you have an excuse it's
my conning skis where did you run off to
a little bit the switch to a buck you're
handsome ha ha
say that again do that again I'm
following the sound of your voice no
louder why I want to find you that's why
ah ha ha ha
do you guys have walked past in making
time yeah yeah why don't you sing it yes
what have you looked at him just saying
yeah
that was good market back good luck at
get wise I think market mama stop
shooting a shotgun man Jesus de Jesus oh
my god come on he's right here you can
you see him done around you you yeah you
say they were messing with me you son of
a [ __ ] hundred what that was new and
take our potatoes forget I got it
continue with the bouncing study a bit
don't drop your on crops